here to explain texas senator ted cruz
senator good to have you back
uh okay those are my five things that i
think we need so we have
integrity in the process and confidence
in the results
am i on target or is there more that you
think we should add
look sean you're exactly right and and
i've got to say this bill that is before
the senate it's s-1 or h-r-1
many of us are calling it the corrupt
politicians act
is in my view the single most dangerous
piece of legislation before
the united states congress you know
there's kind of two buckets of what the
democrats are trying to do one is bad
policy things like
massive new taxes massive new spending
massive new regulations all of those are
going to hurt
americans all across the country but
there's a second bucket that is really
rigging the game trying to change the
rules so they never lose again
and and the crown jewel of the rigging
the game proposals is the corrupt
politicians act
tomorrow in the rules committee in the
senate we're going to have a markup i've
got
46 amendment i've introduced that i'm
going to force democrats to vote on one
after the other after the other because
you're right what this bill does
it's a massive federal takeover of
elections all across this country
it strikes down almost every voter
integrity law that's ever been adopted
in the states so for example
29 states require voter id it's a very
reasonable common sense provision
the corrupt politicians act strikes all
of those laws down
31 states prohibit vote harvesting
prohibited paid operatives
collecting other people's ballots and
potentially stealing those votes
this bill strikes all of those
provisions down
this bill the corrupt politicians act
would register
millions of illegal aliens it would
register millions of criminals to vote
because democrats believe and i think
quite reasonably
that millions of illegal aliens and
millions of criminals are likely to vote
democratic
this bill turns the federal election
commission into a partisan weapon
to find to prosecute to sue republicans
it gives chuck schumer
a federal agency as an attack dog and
not only that
this bill is welfare for politicians it
provides a federal match of
six to one if if a candidate raises
money
uh for a campaign the federal government
matches at
six to one which would give hundreds of
millions of dollars to politicians
because sean as you look at needy
populations in america
it's hard to think of a a group more
needing
of federal funds than politicians and by
the way they can pay their own expenses
out of this this is a
it is a massive democratic power grab
and it's because the number one priority
of joe biden
of chuck schumer and nancy pelosi is to
stay in power for a hundred years
and to steal the rights of the voters to
to vote them out i am
leading the fight against this it is the
single most dangerous thing in the
congress right now
senator i'll defer to you you're the you
went to harvard law you've argued and
one case is before the
the u.s supreme court my understanding
is that
the constitution is pretty clear time
manner
place of elections that would be up to
state legislatures
but maybe i'm mistaken or perhaps i
misinterpreted our constitution
and the very clear language in it well
well sean i will say it it's a bit more
complicated than that because under the
constitution the states and the federal
government
have concurrent authority so so congress
does have some authority
over elections and it would certainly be
litigated
are there provisions of the corrupt
politicians act that any
in any fair court would be struck down
absolutely
but here's the really bad news the only
way the democrats will pass the corrupt
politicians act
is if they can get all 50 democrats to
end the filibuster
if they end the filibuster they'll do
this but they'll also
make dc a state adding two new
democratic senators
and they'll pack the u.s supreme court
adding four left-wing justices
and if they do that four left-wing
justices will vote to uphold the corrupt
politicians act
and keep democrats in power forever this
is all about rigging the game
and stealing your right to vote it's
saying to the voters
you can't vote the bums out no matter
how much damage they do to the country
republicans can deny the democrats a
quorum
if they unite all 50 of you do you trust
lisa murkowski
ben sasse mitt romney because i don't
have a lot of confidence in him
look sean i hope so i can tell you i'm
making the case to my republican
colleagues that if they pull the trigger
if joe manchin and kirsten cinema
cave under chuck schumer's pressure we
should use every
tool we can we should deny unanimous
consents we should deny a quorum
i can tell you most republicans are
agreed i don't know if we get all 50
i'm going to do everything i can to make
the case and i hope we do right now
there's not a republican in the
conference arguing the other side that
might change
but at least right now we have a united
front i hope that remains that way
because if not tax increases we can undo
in two years or four years
changing the rules fundamentally is
designed to rig the system
for a century to come and with every
every breath in my body i'm going to
fight against it
senator i appreciate your efforts this
is important this is key
this is crucial this would forever
change and alter
the trajectory of the country biggest
power grab
ever thank you senator cruz hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else